[Musik]
sie trägt einen weißen pullover ihre
rose ist eng die haare sind unbedeckt so
zeigte sich mariam h wenn sie nicht
unter der beobachtung ihrer
islamistischen brüder stand wenn sie
frei war doch genau dieser wunsch frei
und nach westlichen werten zu leben
wurde der afghanen zum verhängnis ihre
brüder sollen sie getötet und ihre
leiche in einem koffer quer durch
deutschland gefahren haben ein
unvorstellbares verbrechen
nun liegt achtung fahndung die anklage
gegen die brüder vor wir rekonstruieren
eine tat die deutschland tief
erschüttert
mariam flieht 2013 mit ihrer tochter und
ihrem sohn nach deutschland sie lebt
damals in einer höhle und wurde von
ihrem mann ständig geschlagen doch
marian will ausbrechen sie lässt sich
scheiden und zieht mit ihren beiden
kindern hier in dieses flüchtlingsheim
und sie verliebt sich neu sie tanzen sie
ist ohne kopftuch gefilmt form wie sie
in einer shisha bar ein völlig neues
leben leben die brüder schlagen ihre
schwester und ihre kinder beschimpften
sie als [ __ ] und drohen ihr sie
umzubringen wenn sie ihr verhalten nicht
ändert eine drohung die die
vorbestraften männer laut anklage auch
wahr machen
es ist der dreizehnte juli zeit und
zählt locken mariam in ihre wohnung
angeblich wollen sie mit ihr zu einer
wohnungsbesichtigung dann so
rekonstruieren es die ermittler quälen
und würgen sie die junge frau
durchtrennen ihr mit einem kräftigen
schnitt die halsvene und schlagader der
schnitt ist so tief dass knorpel an der
wirbelsäule zertrümmert werden den
brüdern
passte die lebensweise der jungen frau
nächsten fühlten sich verletzt
wurde durch die westliche lebensweise
der jungfrau und daran ist
möglicherweise auch ein motiv für die
tat zu sehen laut anklage kaufen seit
und fährt gegen 11 uhr in einer berliner
primark filiale einen großen koffer
zuvor hatten sie im internet gegoogelt
koffer bis 70 kilo in berlin sie rufen
ein taxi fahren mit dem koffer zum
bahnhof südkreuz um 16 uhr 30 werden die
brüder von einer außenkamera am bahnhof
erfasst vier minuten später betreten die
afghanen die bahnhofshalle sie tragen zu
zweit einen schweren ausgebeuteten
rollkoffer sekunden später müssen sie
absetzen durchatmen um 16 40 ziehen die
brüder den koffer zu gleis 3 und sich
auf einer bank aus den koffer neben sich
guckt der eine entspannt ins handy
andere fahrgäste sitzen direkt dahinter
nichts ahnend was im koffer ist
ermittler rekonstruieren später in dem
koffer liegt maryams leiche ihren kopf
und hals haben die killer mit einer
blauen plastiktüte überzogen an den
handgelenken wurde sie mit klebeband
gefesselt
dort können die polizisten später ein
stück eines abgerissenen plastik
handschuhs sicherstellen mit der dna von
bruder zieht um 17 53 liefen sie ihre
last schließlich in den ic 801 nach
bayern am tag danach sollen sie maryams
leiche in einer grube bei holzkirchen
verzerrt haben bild-reporter kelkheim
berichtet damals von der fundstelle und
jetzt kann man das hier sehen diesen
schrecklichen ja sind schrecklich dem
platz wo sie ihre schwester dann
abgelegt haben sollen wir haben es aus
gemessen das ist rund 50 bis 60
zentimeter tief hat dann 1 50 meter lang
und 90 zentimeter in die breite also ein
wirklich grauenhaftes verbrechen was
hier die anwohner natürlich dann auch
oft wenige tage später werden seit und
sehet festgenommen polizei verhör
offenbar befehl seine kranke
moralvorstellungen er sagt ernsthaft
wenn eine verheiratete frau sich mit
einem fremden mann einlässt müsste sie
ins gefängnis oder sogar sterben neben
der dna spur stützen sich die behörden
auch auf die handydaten der brüder und
den spürsinn eines blut hundes er hatte
in der wohnung eines bruders in taxi und
der rolltreppe des bahnhofs angeschlagen
zeit und zelt sitzen bis heute in u-haft
wir gehen von einem längeren prozess aus
der kann auch konfliktreich seien eine
vielzahl von beweis themen sind
abzuarbeiten es ist mit beweisanträgen
zu rechnen wir haben eine prominente
nebenklage den opfer anwalt des landes
berlin
es wird sich in den sommer hinein ziehen
den beiden angeklagten wird eine
lebenslängliche haftstrafe
es bleibt eine absolut unvorstellbare
tat in so einem koffer ist mariam am
ende entsorgt worden wir wollen über
dieses grausame verbrechen sprechen mit
unserem experten professor christian
matz dorfes bei uns selbst viele jahre
kripo ermittler hier in berlin guten
abend hemmersdorf genommen wir haben
gerade in der maz gesehen da gab es also
am ende die sache die die brüder am ende
er mutmaßlich überführt hat nämlich am
handgelenk des opfers da war klebeband
am klebeband hing ein kleines stück von
einem plastikhandschuhe und in dem
plastikhandschuhe hat man also dna von
einem der brüder gefunden das klingt ja
wie aus einem spielfilm wie gut muss man
da ausgebildet sein als
kriminaltechniker dass man so was am
ende nicht übersieht und am ende eben
dieses beweisstück tatsächlich findet ja
es klingt wie im krimi aber es ist
tatsächlich kriminalistische und
kriminaltechnischer goldstandard das
gibt kaum eine straftat dieser art wo es
keine spuren gibt und dann wird eben
einen gegenstand ein spurenträger
millimetergenau von kriminaltechnikerin
kriminaltechnik untersucht und da sind
biologen chemiker physiker dabei aber
auch speziell ausgebildete polizeibeamte
die charakteristische spuren faserspuren
aber eben auch diana spuren untersuchen
und das hat man hier erfolgreich gemacht
ganz wichtig ist festzuhalten dass der
erfolg dieser sache natürlich davon
abhängt wie die ersten kräfte vor ort
die schutz polizeilichen kräfte der
kriminaldauerdienst und dann auch die
mordkommission arbeiten die
kriminaltechnik ist nur so gut wie das
was zugeliefert werden kann oder was man
im ort noch im originalzustand findet
die staatsanwaltschaft hat in ihrer
allerersten pressemitteilung selbst von
einem sogenannten ehrenmord gesprochen
denn hier gibt es eben um zwei täter die
aus afghanistan kommen ihre spielt eben
eine rolle aus ihrer erfahrung welche
rolle spielt komplett gespielt konkret
der hintergrund der beiden männer für
diese tat
also vorweg ich lehne diesen begriff
ehrenmord ab wenn menschen die in
abhängigkeit und familienverhältnissen
schwächer wehrlos sind nur deshalb weil
sie sich anders verhalten als von ihm
erwartet wird getötet werden oder schwer
misshandelt werden dann hat das mit dem
begriff ehre nicht viel zu tun dass in
straftaten verbrechens tatbestände ein
tötungsdelikt mit mord merkmalen
insofern muss ich mich sehr
zusammenreißen um diesen begrifflich
noch weiter eben dann in einer
einrichtung zu definieren tatsächlich
wird aber der begriff ehrenmord als
arbeitsbegriff benutzt für straftaten
gewalttaten überwiegend oder fast
ausschließlich von männern gegenüber
frauen die aus der brasilianischen sehr
traditionell konservativen strukturen
kommen oftmals religiös geprägt und wo
diese gewalt gegen frauen akzeptiert
wird gesellschaftlich also wo sie nicht
abgelehnt wird das ist schon ein großes
problem mit weiten teilen der welt aber
wir haben häufig auch die situation dass
diese taten oder dieser begriff benutzt
oder zweigen platz für weitere dinge wie
beispielsweise dass frauen kinder die
sexuell missbraucht worden sind dann
später obwohl sie opfer einer straftat
wurden auch noch getötet werden im namen
der ehre und das sind probleme die durch
männer verursacht werden durch eine
bestimmte denkweise und die durch nichts
zu rechtfertigen sind auch nicht durch
religiöse prägung keine religion
schreibt vor dass in bestimmten fällen
bestimmte konzentrationen dieser art ein
mensch zu töten ist wichtige und
richtige worte hermannsdorf in vielen
dank dass sie heute abend bei uns waren
dankeschön
[Musik]